[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when making the sequel to alien james
cameron tried to make his version
different from the original
and not just because he wanted to keep
it fresh he also said the original turns
ripley into a sex object when she strips
down to her underwear
and then she dropped her gear and was in
her panties for the last scene
see that to me that that stepped over
that line this criticism and his means
of addressing it not only explains many
of cameron's decisions in aliens but it
also shows the contrasting styles of
james cameron and the director of the
original alien ridley scott
despite cameron's accusation of sexism
an early draft of the original
alien actually notes that all characters
are unisex and can be played by a man
or a woman the final film mostly
reflects that idea the majority of the
dialogue is gender neutral and nobody
acts particularly feminine or masculine
but even with a genderless script
each actor's gender influences the final
product like when dallas feels the need
to protect ripley from the alien
implying that she's somehow more
vulnerable than he is or there are
slight modifications of dialogue
a male character makes a sex joke that
isn't in the script and was likely
improvised on set and in classic
stereotypical fashion
the woman does not appreciate it i'd
rather be eating something else but
right now which brings us back to the
panties an
article of clothing that certainly would
have looked different if ripley were a
man especially since we do see the men
wearing different underwear in the
opening scene
the final underwear scene in alien is
far from pornographic
as cameron implies but it's obviously
shot in a way that plays up ripley's
nakedness
ripley strips down to get comfortable at
a time when she's actually in the most
danger her exposure highlights the
anxiety of the scene by showing her
vulnerability to the alien lurking in
the shadows
here director ridley scott uses a
classic trope of the horror genre by
having the villain stalk a vulnerable
naked female character a trope similarly
used in psycho and jaws but a perfectly
valid reaction to all this talk of
underwear is simply who cares is this
really a big deal in movies with much
more egregious blood
terror and sexual imagery i don't
understand this
you may not care about the panties but
james cameron certainly did and as a
result his sequel not only changes the
underwear but it also changes ripley
[Music]
for starters cameron changes how ripley
is portrayed in her underwear in a scene
where ripley gets out of cryosleep her
underwear is not only less revealing but
none of the men around her look at her
any differently
and the camera never gazes on her
nakedness like it does an alien in
addition to the change in underwear
cameron avoided making
any female characters vulnerable at any
point hey vasquez
have you ever been mistaken for a man no
have you compare the supporting female
character in each film
an alien lambert is a hysterical mess
who wants to abandon the ship and she
even has a cat fight with ripley but in
aliens
vasquez is muscular has the biggest gun
and sacrifices herself for the team
ripley also changes between films in
alien her character is written as gender
neutral but the film's direction plays
up her femininity to heighten our fear
of the xenomorph
in aliens cameron downplays ripley's
feminine vulnerability but
ironically he also elevates ripley's
womanhood into a crucial element of the
story we find out in the very beginning
of the film that ripley had a daughter
all along who died while she was in
hypersleep from here the story is the
same as the first alien but there's an
additional mother-daughter subplot
between ripley and newt
and both the mother ripley and the
mother alien fight to protect their
young which results in one of the best
movie quotes of all time
get away from her you [ __ ] unlike the
original film's infrequent hints at
gender
aliens regularly reminds us that ripley
is a woman the script intentionally
contains the same male locker room talk
as the original but this time ripley's
the one rolling her eyes
there's some juicy colonist daughters we
have to rescue from their virginity
but cameron also makes her character
more masculine and aggressive
she surprises the male soldiers by
showing she can operate the exosuit
where you want it and when ripley gets
the chance to escape with her life her
desire for revenge goes so far that she
intentionally
angers the mother xenomorph by torching
her eggs a quick look at ripley says it
all
an alien she's escaping in fear with her
flamethrower in
aliens she's facing the mom head on
holding not just a flamethrower but also
a young child
and an extra machine gun and when it
comes to female characters that badass
persona is a james cameron hallmark he
loves writing female characters who can
do pull-ups like vasquez and sarah
connor or who fight men like an avatar
and titanic
[Music]
neither portrayal of ripley is better or
worse both characterizations fit their
respective films alien creates fear by
showing violation
impregnation and sexual assault even
though ripley was written without gender
ridley scott played up her gender to add
to those fears
in contrast cameron set out to write an
action film about revenge
not about fear and vulnerability so he
centered the film around
a core aspect of femininity motherhood
and used it to motivate both ripley and
the mother xenomorph of course the
resolution of this feminine conflict is
actually quite masculine
it's a fight to the death and it shows
cameron's very 80s perspective on female
empowerment
cameron's female warrior take on ripley
is indicative of another one of his
hallmarks
his movies are often tied to american
culture at the time they were made for a
movie that's supposed to take several
hundred years in the future
aliens feels like it takes place in
1980s america apparently in 200 years
business suits will have that 80s popped
collar marines will look like they're
suited up for the jungles of vietnam and
people will still be making jokes about
latinos being illegal immigrants
right somebody said alien she thought
they said illegal aliens signed up
along with the 80s aesthetics the film
also reaffirms the traditional nuclear
family a scene in the director's cut
shows a mother and father disciplining
their misbehaving son and daughter in a
space rover
knock it off i catch either of you
playing in the air just again i'll tell
you high
even on a distant alien planet families
still act like they're straight out of
an 80s sitcom
and by the end of the film ripley has
gained a nuclear family of her own she
has a husband
a daughter and even the android
functions as a sort of loyal pet that
protects the family
in contrast alien feels much more
timeless which reveals the hallmark of
ridley scott
ridley scott's movies have distinct
atmospheres that almost never feel tied
to the time they were made his film
blade runner feels like a completely
foreign world not america in the 1980s
and alien feels just as otherworldly not
a product of the late 70s
in contrast all you have to do to know
when aliens came out is look at the
hairdos or the reebok sneakers perhaps
these differences in style explain the
differences in ripley's character
ridley scott favors atmosphere above all
which means creating a futuristic
gender integrated workplace while also
using horror tropes to heighten fear
but cameron wanted to make a more
culturally aware film that's why ripley
embodies the 80s ideals of female
empowerment through excelling in
traditionally male environments
all things considered the first two
alien movies are perhaps the most iconic
example of both the original
and the revisionist sequel being
exciting unique masterpieces but for
completely different reasons
it's always a difficult task to write a
sequel to a classic movie but aliens
pulls it off because it changed
according to the vision of the filmmaker
aliens may have a similar story
structure to alien but it makes the bold
choice of drastically changing the tone
atmosphere and gender dynamics of the
first film there's a lot of debate
online over which movie is better but
what's the point of choosing when for
once you can have both for a change
thank you to our patrons for supporting
this video if you like what you saw
consider going to patreon.com now you
see it to keep this channel going
the more people who support us the more
freedom we'll have to make more
ambitious and interesting videos
thanks for watching
you